Before any business
problem can be solved,
it's important to know what data is
needed, and what data's available.
The second step in the framework
is understanding the data.
Having a mental model of the business
issue will be helpful in determining
what factors are likely
to drive demand tomorrow.
For example, some factors that
are likely to be important
are the day of the week,
as well as the month and the year.
It'll also to be useful to
know the hour of the day and
the temperature at that hour, and
maybe even the preceding hour.
So we're trying to predict
electricity usage, but
don't know what the temperature
will be tomorrow.
We'll need to make predictions about
the temperature at any given hour.
Now that we have some ideas around our
data needs, we can start to explore data
factors that will help us
predict hourly temperatures.
In this scenario,
we may look at the forecasted high and
low temperatures from
the national weather service.
The number of minutes from
sunrise to start of each hour,
and the temperature for
the same hour of the previous day.
The available data will be important
citing the types of methodologies that
may be used.
Additionally, a solid understanding
of the data is important
to ensure proper analysis.
For example, if you have a data field
that shows the number of employees per
month, it may be important to know if
the value represents the number of
employees at the beginning of the month,
at the end of the month.
Or, the average of the number of
employees at the beginning and
end of the month.
An improper understanding of the data
may result in an incorrect analysis.